atoms in Dayton Ohio I Adam how are you
I'm doing fine Dave Harry today
better than I deserve what's up I'm
looking for a little personal advice
this isn't financial question and I've
got a brother and a sister who both
still live with my mother
they're 36 and 31 what's wrong with them
nothing nothing physically or even
mentally they just they've never grasped
leaving the nest so to speak and I think
my mother is an enabler yeah think of
them doing nothing but it may not work
no no they don't my mom's the very hard
worker she supports them my brother does
a little bit of odd jobs and stuff but I
just it kind of wears on me and it has
been over the years because I've always
worked sometimes a teenager and I'm 32 I
have my own house I've actually that's
my second house that I'm in um you know
I live another state away but I just
feel a little resentment hey I wasn't no
resentment I would feel pity this is a
horrible and I tried giving them advice
over the years I don't want if I said
only advice have any problems your
mother takes care of them yeah their
mother needs advice your mother needs
counseling she's a dadgum poster child
for codependence yes yeah I I said it's
kind of it wears on me
and because I like said I work here well
where are me because your mother's
destroyed your brother and your sister
yeah I think she needs to tell him
they've got to go no she's messed up
their live here big time yeah that's so
sad yeah is there anybody your mother
would listen to I I don't know that does
I don't even know if she will listen to
me and I thought all this over a year I
don't think she will
I think he likes having them around yeah
no and I've told them myself you know
the best thing that ever happened to me
is
me leaving the house at 18 and getting
out on my own and you know sink or swim
well you're not yeah you're not you're
not a 35 year old adolescent yeah that's
right they are yeah I mean they're
emotionally that their emotional state
has been held back it's like they're
still teenagers yeah yeah Thanks and
there's I feel really know some
resistance from them like course about
with that change well I'm saying as far
as you know my lifestyle they I think
they think that I'm too good for what
they do and how you are it is any nice
why that's why they think that because
you are but I've tried giving you're a
fairly normal functioning adult and and
they're completely messed up crazy
people
of course you're better yeah I mean
that's just how that works I mean it's
not make you a better human being but it
may mean your life is so much better of
course they have that sense of because
you're just you walking in the room and
you're like what they should be that
that's good immediately convicts them of
what they should be doing now does your
mother go to church by chance no she
does not okay is there anyone does she
have a brother or a sister yeah she does
does she think that does she think of
either one of them as being wise uh yeah
I would I would think so I mean like I
said like she really lives up to her
brother or she thinks her sister's a
smart woman or something like that I
would talk to one of those uncle's or
aunts and go hey would you go over with
her with me and talk to her and explain
to her that she's completely destroying
her children yeah I think something like
that needs to happen yeah it does I said
I don't know why I feel the way I do but
I don't I just see them I see them
living below poverty well they're always
hurts it hurts me to see them that way
but there's nothing I can do there's no
advice I can do now you hear something
there what's going on here is it is
broken mental health I mean this is
beyond stupid this is yeah this they're
stupid and then there's crazy this is
crazy
here okay
and so uh what what your mother the
message that needs to be delivered to
her mother your mother is that she is
not helping them
she has brought them great harm here she
has stunted their emotional growth yes i
I agree him 100% yeah this is this is
bad right here so uh your your mom's
I mean she's messed up and she's messed
them up this is like something on a bad
movie tell me about it yeah I've even
lived it yeah so I mean you know that
that that's you know now can you fix
this no all you can do is be gentle wise
the firm direct blunt kind with your mom
all of those and all of those things
I've tried to do well what you're going
to have to get somebody with credibility
though because you've got powdered butt
syndrome any time you're trying to give
your parents advice it's always a
problem even in a functional situation
because what somebody's pottered your
butt they don't want your opinion
correct
and your mom's knocking she's not gonna
listen to you you're just the bitter one
that doesn't get all the goodies that's
why she's looking at it
well no I'm actually the only functional
human being in the room here who my
goodness Wow
so sad thanks for calling in you know
I'm not a family counselor guys but I do
so much work around toxic family
situations and I've hung out with
marriage counselors and family
counselors so much over the years while
we're doing financial counseling because
financials always tied into the
functionality of the family
it always is the more functional family
the more likely that you either can
clean up your financial mess or don't
have one in the first place one of the
two if you're fairly functional and you
look up and you go wow we're stupid you
change stupid you start being smart it
turns things around but where you got
stuff like that going on man it's it's a
it's bad bad news now so when you're
wanting to help your adult children or
you're wanting to help your friend or
you're wanting to help your parents with
money or with living situation like that
ladies do it here's what you have to ask
yourself here's what you have to
remember enable errs are the nicest
sweetest people you will ever meet
that's why I will never be in an abler
that's why Kelly will never be an
enabler it's possible James child's
might be an enabler he's a fairly nice
guy but no way you neither okay but I
mean you have to be a nice person you
have to be one of those sweet like sweet
tea sugar sweet people and because then
what happens is is in the name of being
sweet you allow crazy to go on all
around you and stupid dysfunctional
things to go on around you and you call
that being nice here's what you need to
remember if you're facing that you're
not being nice you're actually bringing
harm when you give a drunk a drink you
didn't help the drunk when you give your
child money and they have a heroin
addiction you didn't help your child you
funded their heroin addiction stupid
that's enabling when you allow a 37 year
old to live at home and not work unless
they have some kind of mental deficiency
there's something wrong with you really
at a deep level at very deep level
so you're not being sweet you're a child
abuser when you involve yourself and you
cause funding and support emotional and
financial to someone's misbehavior you
are a by definition an enabler and you
are by definition not helping them you
are bringing them harm so love people
well if you really want to love people
you have to tell them the truth and you
have to help them be what they're going
to be you don't participate in their
insanity you don't go yeah that's
working good for you why don't I just
give you an extra $10,000 and make sure
you stay in heroin what you would never
do that and that woman has stunted her
kids growth you're sitting there with a
28 year old is living at home for the
past five years you're not a good parent
oh you're not a good parent
you brought that kid harm I mean when
their only skill set is Mario at another
level you got a problem this is the Dave
Ramsey show